well I think this is a good point to
open it up so we have plenty of time for
questions and then comments so let's
just do that in the back
who
one two three okay so my name is Arielle
rohas i'm the president and founder of
trans aspirin network a nonprofit
organization working in Brooklyn and I'm
a calumny a columbia alumni as well so
the main reason that made me come here
it wasn't because Columbia but because
of the of the topic that was about to be
addressed and in this beautiful room and
I have the two experiences of being a
Columbia has a student and also be in
the community has a learner and I find a
oh I found a at the moment that I was
implementing my program in the community
that I have this huge amount of
knowledge that Columbia gave me through
the books and the library hours that I
spent I'll Columbia but I didn't know
about I didn't know anything about the
community I was working with and if
everybody here know a Brooklyn is a very
very diverse a social environment with a
lot of a cultures you know mixing to
each other and I my question is how
Columbia can give the students a little
more space to really interact with the
community because the coursework that we
have right now is so intense about
reading and about going to class that we
don't we don't have time to stop I'm
really you know the same the the stairs
of columbia into the community and a we
get really good grades
you know a pause you know B+ but when we
go to the community we get an F and when
community people see a columbia alumni
they say oh here we go the little boy
that want to change the world but we are
completely disqualified because columbia
didn't give us the time at least a day
to go to the community and learn from
them okay that's great thank you so yeah
it's all right hi I really admire what
will you have been done go ahead
continue so so let's take a series of
comments that's the best way to make
sure people get out so yes in the back
way back hi my name is guru Wayne I'm a
documentary filmmaker and I'm currently
doing a film about education in the
context of the 21st century and the
global environment and actually going
off your comment you mentioned a little
bit about the achievement gap and I've
been educated in America as well as in
japan and taiwan and and recently
there's a lot of conversation around how
are we going to compete with these asian
kids who are you know they're just
they're taking our jobs they're they're
testing much higher than us and there's
so many of them right
which is an issue and so there's what
I've been seeing in my research is this
obsession to close the achievement gap
how do we get our kids to test as well
as the kids in Asia but um you know
having been educated in Asia as well
there-there's conversation about how do
you close the the creativity gap and
this is goes with your your your comment
about less cramming and add more
community building figuring out who you
are and how you could be a contribution
and i'm currently looking for funding
for my film so if there's anybody
interested please contact me but I was
you know I guess my question is what
kind of models are you looking at to
close the achievement gap and the
creativity gap because that's that's
what I'm looking for great I know
somebody from a foundation okay couple
more comments and then we'll will takes
to make a comment yeah you bet go ahead
um I will say my experience at Columbia
Law and I I again I will speak it speak
I speak from someone who went to
Columbia as a graduate student a law
student not an undergraduate student but
one of the pivotal moments for me was as
a third year in law school I took part
in the clinic and i would say that many
of the law students at Columbia are
encouraged to take part in the clinic
and mine was prisoners and families and
it was i I think i clearly understood
giving back my father's minister i had
worked at a program prep for prep in the
summer but i felt that in that
experience which was an academic
experience at its base was the first
time that i actually got the chance to
understand that i actually could acquire
an expertise and i could use that
expertise to impact others in a very
real way in the very immediate way and I
you know I learned that in an academic
environment so I say that to say I do
think there are at least in in some of
the schools and it may be an
undergraduate school I don't know I
wasn't there
I I think I had an incredible kind of
community experience while at Columbia
it was the incarcerated community but it
was a case of other comments over here
my name is Farah wazifa I'm a CIPA
alumni from 84 my question is maybe more
focused for Judith Rodin I want to bring
up a gender dimension to the issue which
you've posed here more specifically
because i work on women's empowerment
issues back home in pakistan and if i
want it if you could highlight some
specific you know aspects which you
faced as a member of the female
community and what advice would you give
to current people in the future to look
out for because i feel that especially I
see Rockefeller Foundation has done a
report schreiber report and it shows
more women in the workforce this year
thank you and do you want to respond to
that I had a very tough graduate school
career as a woman in in a lab based
science and I do think that the
experience for women in the Academy has
improved dramatically I mean I'm the
first woman Ivy League President and so
obviously I probably am the instance of
its improvement but I do think and what
was interesting in the Shriver report
was the fact that even in the United
States where we've made such remarkable
advances women are still learning 77
cents on the dollar equating education
and job training so I think we haven't
gotten all of the way and I think that
these are really important issues but
all of our do
versity issues require increasing
vigilance we can't just say I've solved
that now we'll move on to the next issue
we are very complex diverse society here
and around the world our diversity is
increasing New York City obviously is
extraordinarily diverse and in gender
and sexual preference and race and
ethnicity and in country of origin and
so we're in a wonderful laboratory if
you will in New York as well as in other
places in the world to experiment with
what it means to really rise to the
challenges of diversity and those are
challenges that in a way some of the
questions really addressed community
diversity is something that we need to
have more experience with ethnic and and
an international diversity is something
and gender diversity still and so I
think we should practice here and that's
why I'm so glad you're in your job
because I do think it's not only
volunteerism it's what we need to get
out of volunteerism not only what we're
putting into a food and if we're not
coming out of that service experience
and experience having learned something
about ourselves which is critical but
having learned how to live with people
who are quite different from us then I
think we're wasting our time even though
we're doing a little bit of good it's
that
so I can't really see